you've expressed concern about low
interest rates that often lead to higher
debt burdens and inflation would you say
that characterizes what's happening in
the united states right now i view it
just very much mechanically
buying power
which comes in the form of money and
credit
when that's produced in a quantity
which is much greater than the
incremental production of goods services
and financial assets
drives those financial asset prices to
go up
and the printing of money
the monetization of debt
is a last phase in a long-term debt
cycle because it indicates that when
there's a lot of debt and there's um
a zero interest rate and you print that
money that debt monetization has its
effects so what we're seeing now in the
market is very very very classic it's
happened repeatedly
in that that enormous amount of buying
power created by the creation of money
which doesn't raise living standards
that is passing through the system and
so you're seeing it happen in the
inflation of goods services and
financial assets